sieht so die große liebe aus das hier
ist robert crumb und das einkommen
skicross seit 45 jahren ein liebespaar
und ich fühle mich so geborgen den arm
dieser starken jüdischen frau er ist
nicht jüdisch hat aber eine große nase
eine schlechte haltung sieht nicht gut
plus er lamentiert und merkt viel besser
als ich hier sieht man die beiden im
wirklichen leben und hier im bett bei
der lektüre eines comics in dem sie sich
selbst gezeichnet haben so waschen sie
ihre private schmutzige wäsche seit
jahrzehnten wie alle ausstellen
cartoonmuseum basel zeigt wie wir heute
ins museum gekommen sind war da ein typ
der offensichtlich unsere arbeit kennt
das war uns und fing an zu machen er
starrt uns an und sagt oh gott es gibt
sie wirklich ein bisschen halt figur
massimo cartoons in persona und lachte
nur über donald tag persönlich sehen
würde
seit 45 jahren geht es nun schon so
jeder arbeitet für sich als künstler und
gleichzeitiger finden sie geschichten
über sich selbst
ohne tabus und immer nah an ihrer
lebensrealität
in der 3
du bist zunächst spezialisten
wir haben einen ähnlichen humor
vielleicht weil wir schon so lange
zusammen sind
vielleicht ist das aber auch der grund
warum wir zusammen sind wir harmonieren
intellektuell ich finde immer komisch
sie haupt nicht immer um danke lieber
sie sagt sehr witziges zeug
sie hat diesen natürlichen jüdischen
humor diesen fatalistischen den
selbstironischen humor der mich dauernd
zum lachen bringt
das enge kraft ksc schwarz weiße amerika
projekte beider kindheit eine saubere
wohlstands welt beherrscht vom strikter
moral der größte feind war der
kommunismus und geküsst wurde im
autokino roberts vater war ein
ehemaliger soldat der us-armee streng
katholisch tyrannisch
berlin wuchs in einem jüdischen milieu
an der ostküste auf auch sie entfloh
einer kaputten familie zuerst nach new
york dann in san francisco der 1970 er
jahren drogenfrei liebe selbstbestimmung
und dann begegnet sie ausgerechnet
robert kromm
er war bereits zum helden der
underground comic szene aufgestiegen
mit figuren wie fritz the cat dem sex
besessenen krater roberts themen sind
vor allem seine sexuellen vorlieben
er erfindet figuren wie hans kaminski
geht auffällige ähnlichkeiten aufweist
mit aliens g obwohl er sie noch gar
nicht kennt
elin schreibt zur selben zeit den ersten
autobiografischen comic goalie andy
roddick in dem sie ihre verkorkste
kindheit thematisiert ein meilenstein
der comicgeschichte und sie
veröffentlichten einem feministischen
comic kollektiv namens willens comics
das war eine schwierige situation
egal diesen humorlosen feministinnen als
ich zugab dass ich immer noch auf männer
stehe ich gerne sexy anziehe und dennoch
mein leben selbst bestimmen
das war politisch inkorrekt sie regelt
mit bass und behandelten mich wie eine
verräterin
ich wurde zum risiko in der gruppe sie
war auch eine verräterin weil sie mit
mir was an in einem touristischen
schweinen sexistischen frau lassen sie
waren die vertreterinnen des im
feministischen comics kollektiv der sehr
spezielle wahnsinn ihre beziehung wird
zu einer serie von comics die sie
gemeinsam zeichnen
entspann dich ich helf dir und hörte
streiten robert sonst verhärten deine
arterien
sie erzählen von sex und jetzt werde ich
dir dieses häuschen für ein paar minuten
haus ziehen und den obsessionen einer
speziellen liebe
robert zeichne tim robert und elin
zeichnet im rallye am anfang hatten
viele kommen fans diese zusammenarbeit
mit berlin bekam brief in dem es hieß
sie mag ja gut im bett sein aber halt
sie aus den comics ich habe eine lange
liste mit solchen bemerkungen bereite
sie für die küche nun aber zeigt es die
cartoons es ist anders gekommen und die
basler ausstellung liefert den beweis
dafür
für eine verrückte verschrobenen
abgründige liebes und arbeitsbeziehung
wohin fliegen wir eigentlich
ich suche einen planeten auf dem ich so
viele ehemänner und schuhe haben kann
wie ich wählen